- [Mark] All right, Luciano.
- How's it going?
- [Mark] Luciano, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from, originally?
- [Luciano] I'm originally
from right here,
South Central L.A.
- [Mark] And tell me about
you. How you grew up.
- I grew up in a two-parent home.
My dad worked two jobs.
But I grew up right there in the projects.
Right there in the Pueblo Del Rios,
and the Nickerson Garden
projects, as well.
- [Mark] And how would you
describe your childhood?
- To me?
I don't know, I'm a lone star.
Like, I got a big family,
but I live by myself.
I like to do things solo.
I like to be in my own little world, but
I grew up,
I grew up in a very good,
I mean a great family,
you know what I'm saying?
I got a gang of brothers and sisters.
I guess like, 16 brothers, 14 sisters.
So, yeah, I got a big family.
- [Mark] You went through high school?
- Yeah, I went to high school.
Graduated.
Well, I graduated in a contin-
Well.
What's that's extenuation thing?
- [Mark] GED?
- Extenuation?
- [Mark] Yeah, but you got through?
- Yeah. I got through.
- [Mark] Did you have
dreams of doing something
with your life, when you were young?
You're still young. How old are you?
- I'm only 31.
- [Mark] 31. Yeah, you're young.
- Yeah.
I have dreams doing a lot of things.
Music was one of them.
But I like to write
though, mostly anything.
You feel me?
I'm a big reader. Read anything.
Doesn't matter what it is.
I'll pick it up and read it.
- [Mark] But here you are in the streets.
- Yeah. Because the epidemic, you feel me?
I really got out.
Only been out for like
maybe a year, two months.
- [Mark] From where?
- From Roseville State Prison.
But I went to Corporon.
I did my last couple of
months in the shoe, for one.
- [Mark] What were you in there for?
- Well, they found narcotics
in my room, you feel me?
But my release date,
my release date beat them to the,
will beat the investigation, so.
But, they still got two
years to file on me.
Anytime. Anytime they want to.
But,
I mean, what can I say?
- [Mark] So, so you're,
you're helping some
of the girls though. On Figueroa, right?
- You can say that me, you feel me?
I basically let them do them.
You feel me? At the end of the day,
whether they with me or not,
they'll be out there doing it anyway.
You feel me?
So, it's just money management.
I'm like a bank.
- [Mark] How do you describe
your role in their lives?
- I'm just a monolith and
they just need structure.
They just looking for a home,
a place to be. You feel me?
They looking for love to
too, at the same time.
But I mean, I don't sugar coat nothing
with them or none of that,
and they know what time it is.
You feel me?
I'm just gonna do me.
But the girls, I don't.
They come along, they fine.
Little issues every now and then
but not so much as I can handle.
- [Mark] Did you see
yourself almost as a, like a
life coach?
You give them guidance?
- I'm gonna say a motivational speaker.
You feel me?
At the end of the day, I'm not
going to bring my girl down.
I'm trying to uplift them.
You feel me?
I'm trying to motivate them.
Keep going. Continue to go get it.
And then they, you feel me?
Like, my little brother, you feel me?
He's rapping. He's on
YouTube and all that.
You feel me?
They call them K.O.
He said,
"Watts, W-A-T-T-S. We
are taught to survive."
- [Mark] What's that mean?
We are taught to survive.
- [Mark] Oh.
- So.
I mean, it was the truth though.
We really are.
But, I mean, the girl got
to do what they got to do.
Just like I got to do what I got to do.
At the end of day, I'm down
just on the streets too either.
You feel me?
I make moves and do other things.
I'm not just sitting there
watching them and all that.
- [Mark] And what, what kind
of guidance will you give them?
- Some of they past, little situations
with other people and all that.
Other people they done been with,
like,
like a form of torture.
Like it's meant to break them down,
to build them back up.
Like, I'm trying to wipe all that out.
Like all that, what they were
doing, burning them girl.
I'm putting them in cold water.
Like,
some of the stuff
I hear it's, like, amazing,
for real, for real.
But they strong, though.
They survive.
At the end of the day,
they, they keep going.
You feel me? So.
- [Mark] So, you see what you do is,
kind of, as you're helping
build them back up.
- Basically, got them.
They ain't gotta be out there like that.
They can do other stuff. You feel me?
I mean, whether they choose
to do with their money or not.
Whether they give it to me
or do it to the next person
at the end of the day, you feel me?
It's they decision. Period.
It ain't mine.
- [Mark] How many girls
do you do this with?
- Right now?
I'm currently at maybe
16, 17 girls right now.
You feel me?
But some get along, some don't.
So, the ones who don't,
they got to get a room
by herself or whatever.
- [Mark] And this is a, a romantic
or a sexual relationship
with some of them?
- No, only one of them.
- [Mark] Only on of them?
- Only one of them, but
with the others,
I mean.
I mean, with the others,
I mean, it is what it is.
I mean, what can I say?
- [Mark] Right. Are drugs
a part of your life?
- For marijuana? Yeah.
You feel me?
I don't drink, you feel me?
I just smoke marijuana.
- [Mark] That's it?
- That's it.
I let the, I mean-
- [Mark] A lot of the
girls will use the stuff?
- Some, some do, but I
don't really like it.
But at the same time, you feel me?
I'm not about to try to enforce them
to do anything.
At the end of the day, they grown women.
They gonna do what they want to do.
You feel me?
And the day long.
As long as I get what I need,
I ain't tripping.
- [Mark] They're free to go?
- Yeah, they free to go
do whatever they want.
I'm not about to take all your stuff.
None of that.
At the end of the day,
I bought it for you.
You can have it. Do your thing.
You feel me?
At the end of the day,
ain't nobody gonna treat
you like me, anyway.
So, go ahead.
Tell you the truth, they
really don't even wanna leave.
- [Mark] Did the girls come to you?
Did the girls choose you or do you-
- No, they choose me.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- You feel me?
At the end of the day, I feel like
all the girls I got, they all chose me.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- You feel me?
I accepted them.
But for sure, they chose me.
- [Mark] Right.
- Because I don't go out
there scouting and looking.
I mean, they see something,
obviously, they like.
You feel me?
- [Mark] Do you have any gang history?
- You can say that.
You feel me?
I'm part of the west side Denver Lanes.
- [Mark] The streets, the gangs, all them?
Yeah, I associate, but not like that.
You know, I'm in and out.
I let them do them, I'm a do me.
I ain't worried about the street politics
or what goes on in the streets.
I'm worried about me.
I'm don't worry about what
people think about me,
what they got to say, no, none of that.
At the day, that doesn't
even matter to me.
It's your opinion.
I really don't give a
fuck about your opinion.
You feel me?
- [Mark] Do you have kids of your own?
- Yeah. I got kids of my own.
- [Mark] And are you raising them?
- Somewhat but not really, but-
I mean,
in my case, when they come to me,
they ask me,
I'm just right there.
You know what I'm saying?
At the end of day, I'm in a
little situation with my kids.
Well, not with them, but with the parents.
We don't always see eye to eye, so.
At the end of the day,
they know I love my kids,
you feel me?
But,
I am with them.
And then I'm about to have another one.
Period.
- [Mark] Yeah. One of your
girls is pregnant, right?
- Hm?
- [Mark] One of your girls
is pregnant right now.
- We might be having twins.
- [Mark] Twins?
How many kids do you have already?
- It's going to be my fourth one.
I mean, the twins going to be.
If they twins, for sure.
That'd be four but I
only got two right now.
I have one girl.
I got a son that's 16.
About to go play football,
college football.
I got a daughter that's 12.
You feel me? She's still
getting to know herself though.
I mean, I'm here for them
whenever they need me.
But as far as they mama go,
I ain't got nothing to do with my kids.
- [Mark] What personality
trait do you possess
that makes this
situation that you've built possible?
Where multiple women are
coming to you for guidance,
giving you their money,
all that kind of stuff.
- [Luciano] I don't know. I'm not-
I'm just me.
I'm just myself.
I don't know.
People get just the assumption that,
oh, I talk like a pimp, I
might be a pimp or whatever.
I mean.
If they see it that way,
I guess that's what it is.
But I don't see it that way.
You know what I'm saying?
At the end of the day, like I said,
I'm not forcing them to do anything.
I'm not beating on them, abusing them.
None of that.
They can leave, free to go whatever.
Me chasing money and all that,
we doing, our doing. Never going to stop.
- [Mark] The word I heard on the street is
there's another personality.
Another side of your personality
than what I'm seeing right now.
- [Luciano] Oh yeah, for sure.
Yeah, for sure. When
I get mad and this is,
it's a wrap, like.
(laughs)
- [Mark] I haven't seen that,
but I've heard about it.
- [Luciano] Yeah, I man.
It's devastating because
it may be the truth though.
I ain't gone lie, it
might be the truth but,
my anger always gets the best of me.
That's why I don't like to get mad.
- [Mark] Well, there's,
there's so much BS out there.
- [Luciano] For sure, for sure, it is.
- [Mark] And the way to
deal with it sometimes is...
- [Luciano] Yeah, people lie so much.
They pretend to be something they not.
- [Mark] Is it difficult to be around
so many people that are hustlers,
that are just up to no
good. That are troubled?
- I don't keep none of
them bastards around me.
For sure.
If you grind me, I'm
going to tee it off top.
I remove them out my way.
All I need is positive people around me.
That's it.
No negativity. No, none of that.
If you ain't trying to do nothing
with your life, then yeah.
Go kick it with the people who
ain't trying to do
nothing with their life.
At the end of the day, I got places to be.
I'm trying to do something.
I'm trying to get to where I need to go.
Move out my way.
You feel me?
I'm gonna go around you,
over you, under you.
At the end of the day, man, I pretend
like I don't even see
people half of the time.
You feel me?
All the time, people come
to me and they be talking.
I really don't be listening.
I mean, my mind be somewhere else.
Somebody told me the other
day, like you wake up,
like every all day, every
day is money on your mind.
That's all you think about. For sure.
I eat, breathe, shit money.
That's all I'm gonna think about.
That's all I been thinking about.
That's all I've been chasing.
I'm going to go get it.
- [Mark] What's more important?
Money or love?
- Tell you the truth,
right now, I'm a say,
neither one.
'Cause I'm not materialistic.
I don't really care about money.
You feel me?
But for sure, for sure,
I will hold on to it.
But if you ask me for
it, I'll give it to you.
Just as fast as I gave it to you,
just as fast I'm gonna make it back.
- [Mark] What's most important to you.
- Loyalty.
- [Mark] Loyalty.
- That's it.
That's all I care about.
You feel me?
At the end of the day, as long as you do
what you're supposed to do.
All I'm trying to do is motivate people
to keep going out there to
go do what you gotta do.
Stop trying to be lazy and all that.
Sit on your ass and don't do nothing.
My sister worked three jobs.
She would get up every morning.
You know what I'm saying?
What the hell I look like?
Laying right there while
she get up every morning.
No, hell no.
I'm gonna go get it too.
So, when she was getting up,
if I wasn't up before her,
she was up before me.
But for sure, we was up,
both leaving out the door,
right behind each other.
So.
- [Mark] So many people say that
with the girls that we're talking about,
girls that work Figueroa, for example,
do for a living is wrong and
the girls are being forced into that or
it's just not right for
them to be doing it.
- I mean, but at the same time,
them people looking from the outside.
They not this person.
They're not living her life.
- [Mark] What do you think most outsiders
don't understand about that life?
- Most of these girls don't
have no father figure around.
Most of these girls was raped, abused.
You know what I'm saying?
This is the only thing.
This is what they only know.
Some of these girls
didn't even go to school.
You feel me?
Some did.
I know a lot of them
I went to school with,
they out there.
You feel me? Don't have to
be, but they choose to be.
Got good families and everything.
But who am I to judge them?
End of the day, leave that
to God. Live your life.
If that's how they want
to live their life,
let them live it.
You feel me?
Period. Leave them alone
- [Mark] Is your attitude
that they're going to
be out there doing it anyway?
They're lost and they need some guidance.
- I mean, I feel like there's, as people,
we're not perfect. We ain't God.
That's the only person that was perfect.
You feel me?
We all make mistakes. You feel me?
But who am I to judge
them on their mistakes?
Whether they learn from them or not.
At the end day, they gotta,
they gotta live their life.
They got to go through what
they got to go through.
It's light at the end
of the tunnel. Period.
Can't be too many, much
dark nights and stormy days.
You know what I'm saying?
When they ready to quit,
when they ready to see that
light at the end of the tunnel,
they'll go get it.
Some will make it, some won't.
And the ones that won't,
they still be out there.
When we long dead and gone,
as they still live in wherever,
they still be out there.
- [Mark] Yeah.
Tell me your thoughts on karma.
- On karma?
- [Mark] Yeah.
- I don't believe in it.
I don't believe in it.
I don't believe in karma.
At the end of the day, I feel like
people do wrong.
At the end of the day,
it's just common sense.
Right and wrong.
At the end of the day, you know
what you're doing is wrong.
If you choose to continue to do that,
then that's what you continue to do.
I want to be treated how
I want others treat me.
So, for sure, show my kindness.
I'm going to be respectful.
As soon as you disrespect
me, oh, for sure,
I'm gonna disrespect your ass back.
Know what I'm saying? So.
But, I'm gonna respect everybody.
I don't care if I don't know you.
I'm a respect everybody.
People, they see me,
when they see me coming, they,
oh, he's a thug.
Until they hear me speak,
And then it's like, oh, no.
But, for sure, I'm not
dumb at all. Whatsoever.
But, I let people do what they do.
- [Mark] And what's the
most important lesson
you've learned in your life?
- Patience.
And to understand people.
For some reason, I can
just talk to a person
and I can just,
just get it.
Just like, yeah.
I don't have to be told
like, oh, you know something?
No, I already know.
For sure, all these
girls ain't got it all.
They ain't got it all.
And the ones who do, they the lucky ones.
But for them girls to be doing drugs,
and selling they body, and
been through the abuse,
and the rape, and everything like that?
You feel me?
They use the drugs at the getaway.
They use sex as a getaway
Some don't like it. Some do.
But for sure, if people really cared,
people would be out
there helping them girls.
You feel me? After we kind
of walking down the street,
you feel me?
Your girl ain't got no place to go to.
No, none of that.
So, you mad at the person
that's basically giving them home.
Taking, basically, taking care of them.
They can't take care of their self.
They family won't take care
of them because what they do.
- [Mark] Yeah, the situation
that I see over and over again,
is that the drugs are a
big part of the picture.
- Drugs.
Drugs messed up pimping.
- [Mark] Yeah. I mean, the
crystal meth, especially
- Oh yeah, for sure.
That's just a new crack era.
For sure, for sure.
That's everywhere.
Only whites and Hispanics doing it.
My blacks doing it.
That's a whole new market.
That's a whole new money thing.
- [Mark] And then you get
the riskier sex requests.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And then the
whole thing just kind of,
problems spread from there.
- I understand that different drugs,
affect different people different.
We can hit the same drug.
You will die or go crazy.
And I'll still be the same person.
That's amazing to me.
That's crazy.
But it's like that.
Somebody hits something,
and, for sure, this person that hit it,
won't nothing happen.
He'll hit it and then he'll die.
Just off one hit.
- [Mark] Yeah.
What are the different
behaviors you see from people?
- Oh, yeah. For sure.
- [Mark] You know, the tricks are high.
The girls are high, very often.
- But...
That drug really drove down prices.
You feel me?
You got a crack head out here
giving head for $20, $15.
Then you got to girl, a real hoe out here,
who really trying to get her money.
She charged him 60, maybe $75.
For sure, he don't want that.
He'd rather go get his dick
sucked by the crack head.
You feel me?
Then to go get one by a decent girl,
that's clean and all that.
You ain't got to worry about nothing.
You feel me?
But they willing to take the risk.
Now some of these cops?
Be amazing.
Some of these dudes be
loan officers.
You feel me?
Working corrections and government,
and it'd be crazy.
They be wanting some of the weirdest ever.
The girlfriend experience.
That shit's just crazy.
They want to bareback,
go kissing, and all that.
Like you want to kiss on a prostitute?
You want to go bareback with a prostitute?
Like for sure, for sure?
That is some weird, crazy shit.
I just don't know.
But, good thing about pimps,
for sure, pimps keep they girls clean.
Make sure they stay with
condoms and everything.
You feel me?
And they, for sure, she gone to do it.
She might as well.
She'll be safe doing it.
You don't want to lose your girls to
no AIDS or, you feel me?
Basically, overdosing on drugs.
So for sure, for sure.
Ain't nothing about that.
And some of these pimps
actually take care of they kids
and send their kids to
daycare and shit like this.
This shit is-
I'm just saying.
But, for sure, this new age
pimping, is dumb as hell.
Show boating, all on Fig.
Making a scene of themself.
Flossing with these girls. Money.
You feel me?
Ain't really doing nothing with it.
Some started businesses.
And then they, the whole point is
to get the girls off the street.
Make enough money off the streets
and put them into businesses where
they can clean make the
money, bring the money back.
You know what I'm saying?
Doing something different,
doing something positive.
To where they can have a life of they own.
You feel me? Some let go, some don't. But-
I just learned to be patient
and be able to learn people,
be able to read people.
- [Mark] How would you describe yourself?
Would you call yourself a pimp,
or do you call yourself a hustler?
One of the girls I
interviewed recently, Royalty,
called you, some of these
guys, the hoe hustlers.
- Hoe hustlers. Pimps is
the biggest hoes ever.
- [Mark] How would you describe yourself?
- Me?
I don't know. I'm just simple.
Like, I ain't no hustler,
I ain't no con artist,
I ain't money hungry.
No, none of that.
I'm just like, I just want to live.
I don't want to survive.
Fuck surviving.
I'm going to live like
everybody else's living.
Maybe even better.
If you want it, you gone go get it.
If you don't, shit,
you'll be out here on skid
row, walking around with them
- [Mark] Good shout out.
Thank you so much for sharing your story.
- [Luciano] Yep.
- [Mark] I wish you the
best of luck out there, man.
- [Luciano] All right. Thank you.
- [Mark] Thank you.